MARK BENNETT: My name is Mark Bennett.
In fact, I am still a newcomer on the Google and Google Play teams.
Because I just got started in January this year.
But this year I really benefited a lot.
Play is a passionate and challenging business
I am honored to witness some of the things that happened.
Our agenda today is quite compact
Today, everyone will still hear
Let's introduce more cool content
My task is simple
It is about the development of Play and Android in Europe, the Middle East and Africa.
Then let's get started.
Let's first talk about our Android platform.
Android platform since its release
Has achieved rapid growth in the past 7 years
Last year we announced a milestone with amazing numbers.
That is, the number of effective devices currently exceeds 1 billion.
This is incredible
Another incredible number is
The number of activations per day reaches 1.5 million
Obviously, this reflects Android
Success in the field of smartphones and tablets
In addition, Android is also constantly expanding to other platforms.
Such as Android TV, wearable devices
Even a car
As the ecosystem continues to expand
The number of OEMs working with us will also increase
More than 200 OEMs have developed Android products.
This number is also amazing
The last part about the ecosystem
Operator partnership
We and the world
More than 330 operators cooperate to sell Android devices
Play users can also purchase devices from them
Then, when it comes to market share, it’s also a great achievement.
This is Android's market share in the smartphone market in Europe, the Middle East and Africa.
Share a good news with you here.
That is, our market share has been growing since last year.
This is the result of our collaboration with a research company called Canalys.
This share has increased from 72% to 77%
It can be said that our development momentum is booming.
And our development on the tablet is also very good.
Currently, three-fifths of tablets in Europe, the Middle East and Africa are powered by Android.
The same is a strong development momentum
And the future is bright
Forecasts show that in the next 5 years
The number of smartphones will double
By 2019, smartphones in Europe, the Middle East and Africa will exceed 1.25 billion
You can see the biggest share of this growth.
Will come from Android
To mention, this is the big piece of green in the bar chart.
So that everyone didn't notice
The development trend in the next few years is worth looking forward to.
Because Android will continue to open up new markets.
Especially worth looking forward to
These emerging markets
Last year, we talked about Android One.
At the time, our product director Michael Siliski
Announced the plan
That is Google wants to expand Android's market share in emerging markets.
Even though we have achieved the above growth
But only a quarter of the world’s people own smartphones.
And Google’s ambition is to let the remaining 5 billion people
Can also access the Internet via mobile devices
Android One is our OEM
A plan jointly launched by chip manufacturers
Designed to deliver high quality hardware at a very low cost
Pushing to these emerging markets
About Android One, I guess what is most expecting everyone.
Or the things that everyone is most interested in.
No, these devices are equipped with the latest version of the Android system.
We all know that this is very important
Last year, we announced
Bring Android One to market
I am very happy to tell you here.
So far we have launched Android One in several countries, including India, Pakistan, Thailand
Indonesia, Philippines, Nigeria and Turkey
In addition, Android One is expanding its market in Europe, the Middle East and Africa.
We promoted it to Egypt, Ghana, Kenya
Spain, Morocco and Egypt
I seem to have said Egypt twice.
The growth momentum is amazing
We are really happy to see Android One
Can make more users in emerging markets
Enjoy a truly high quality experience at a low cost
The size of the Android market is so big, I think
It’s no exaggeration to say that Android is the world’s largest application platform.
More than 1 million apps are currently available in the Play Store.
The number of downloads has reached 50 billion, which is really amazing.
Android users can be in nearly 200 markets
Download your app
And it’s important to pay for these apps in 134 markets.
We all know that paying is the key
In the past year, we have been in 32 markets.
Added 61 payment methods
This makes more than 400 million Android users
Ability to purchase apps on Play with a new payment method
In addition, we have increased payment methods in some key areas.
Allow users to shop on Play with different payment methods
The market that supports DCB payment methods has increased from 25 in 2014 to 37 today.
Just a few weeks ago
We talked to Russian telecom operator MTS about a big deal.
Now we are in the Russian market
Almost all operators can be deducted
The market for gift card payments has increased from 18 in 2014 to 28 today.
The last thing to say is the Paypal payment method we just launched last year.
Now available in 21 markets
Such as in the German market
It has greatly promoted our business development
We are very happy to see this February
Annie mentioned the scale of Google Play development in Germany
More than Apple's App Store
Therefore, increasing the payment method will help promote the development of the entire ecosystem.
The good news is that our developers are like everyone here.
Can get a return
In 2014 we announced the amount paid to developer partners
From $5 billion in 2013 and $2 billion in 2012
Increased to $7 billion today
It can be said that our development momentum is still booming and the business is also developing rapidly.
The outlook is a good one.
Today, everyone will hear about many topics.
Let you know how we keep listening to everyone’s opinions
And how to build a better platform for you.
For everyone to distribute their apps, discover and monetize customers
And I will talk about three important topics today.
Including more effective ways to explore business opportunities
That’s how we can help you discover users in your app.
Use more tools to help you publish your app with confidence
And help you find and retain users more easily
First, let's talk about how to find business opportunities in a more efficient way.
Play platform allows you
Products that are built and released to the market by themselves
Connect with users with the same interests, enthusiasm, and needs
One of our key tasks is
Strive to create a personalized and tailored store experience
So that users are constantly coming to us.
Let them find the ideal application
And the games that they can’t put down
Feel happy
First, let’s make the Play Store very personal.
We have begun to take full advantage of Google’s expertise in machine learning.
To provide a more personalized service
Display recommended content that meets your needs immediately after the Play user logs in to the store
In addition, we are creating more app collections
And will add more types of personalized services
Because we know to provide users with recommendations that meet their needs.
Can double the number of app downloads in the store
We also added a guided search function
In this way, users who access Play only need to search
Generic terminology
Like "photography"
The system will then display a list of related applications.
Various apps that match the search terms like "photography"
Will be displayed together
Taking "photography" as an example, the system will display the photo editing application and the collage application for the user.
we all know
We know that when a user searches for a particular word
Give it a wider range of applications
Can increase downloads
the last one
We are more concerned about the field of development
Is a topic-based discovery feature
We feel that topic-based recommendations are more interesting to users.
Rather than casually judging
Recommend some apps to users
For example, put together a series of applications
For popular search content types for the weekend
There are also games that users can enjoy.
We think this is the way
Can also deepen interaction with Play Store users
The family has always been a field that Google values.
I believe everyone has seen that Google has put a lot of effort into it.
Ensure that our products and services are more closely linked to home and home security
The same is true for Play.
We have been with many people before the I/O conference.
Started cooperation on content grading and submission
To classify your applications into the family experience.
We have previously announced this measure.
Now you can see relevant navigation information in the Play Store.
Convenient for parents according to different age groups
Search by batch, even by popular characters
To find content that suits you and your family
This is a very crucial step for us.
We found a home browsing experience
The number of applications has risen sharply
So if you have a family-friendly app
Be sure to classify them appropriately and include them in the “Family” section.
Also, besides letting our users
Find quality apps and games more easily
We are constantly listening to your opinions and building more powerful tools.
So that you can publish apps and get users.
More important is to let you know how you can optimize your product.
To retain these users
As you can see, the number of tools and features
Growing year by year
We will also introduce to you
More upcoming cool features and services
Help you build better apps
In the months of communication with developers
One topic I have been hearing is
That is, Play can help you make repeated improvements.
Let you get your product to market quickly
Select user groups to test to find possible and infeasible designs
It's easy for you to decide how to invest to get users
And learn how to lose before users
Retain these users
Before I start introducing my theme
I want to share three examples.
The first example is Wooga
I was lucky enough to travel to Berlin early this year.
Visited Wooga employees in their great office
I know that some of them have come today.
I am very happy to hear them again how to use them.
Beta test, phased release
Understand what aspects of the app are loved by users
And why users give up using their apps.
They are the first to make repeated improvements on the Android platform.
This makes me very happy
Everyone should have noticed an application in today’s opening video.
Olivier, founder of RogerVoice, shares an exciting entrepreneurial story
This application has revolutionized the telecommunications industry
It allows people with hearing impairments to communicate by phone.
He is the same as Wooga
Also make repeated improvements on the Android platform.
In fact, it is also preferred to release the app on the Android platform.
Finally, I want to share a good case.
This case comes from our developer My.com in Russia.
They developed an excellent war game "Might and Glory"
They’re giving priority to publishing this game on the Android platform. It’s really super wise.
This is the end of my speech.
I hope everyone on Google Play on the Android platform.
A deeper understanding of business scale, success stories, and bright prospects
Today our purpose is mainly to provide more information for everyone.
But also to listen to everyone’s opinions.
Get more feedback and let us know how we can
Make Play a better platform
Therefore, I am very much looking forward to discussing with you as much as possible today.
thank you all!